[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joke bro
[Music]
immortal masks is a mask and creature
company in Hollywood California
[Music]
oh my god it's gritty
[Music]
their clients have included Netflix
and Warner Brothers and Renaud came from
a profit off X mostly for film and
television which is where we learned a
lot of the techniques and materials and
things that go into making stuff like
this
I just got my nails did
[Music]
the process for a new mask starts with a
drawing or a creature design and Raj
Bravo valleys water creature today
Anju and his team of artists take ideas
from drawings and pictures then sculpt
them into realities their sculptures
provide the basis for each masks design
it's always kind of keeping in mind how
the characters gonna look and try to
make it look as cool as possible while
also thinking about the function and how
it's going to move
once the sculpture is complete the mold
gets prepared a head sack made of power
mesh goes onto the mold before it gets
cast the mesh will become part of the
mask blending extra durability and I
can't tear it if I was doing this
without power mesh I was a ruthless
monster
[Music]
next the mold is closed and the silicone
is cast this is a direct casting light
out of the mold
I think the mass pours from down here it
fills from the bottom up
they cast in high grade silicone which
is not only skin safe but actually
resembles skin the broadcasting then
goes through a few rounds of patching
and semen this is done using a thicken
form of the silicone in the casting next
the mask is ready for paint
[Music]
[Music]
the painted mask then goes on to the
finishing tip where it gets the final
touches such as horns teeth and hair
[Music]
immortal customizes its masks and props
for a variety of different purposes many
of their orders come from regular people
who are looking for a great Halloween
costume some of the top clients are
theme parks and haunted attractions
they've also made masks for music videos
like futures video for mascot
for me being you know the artist behind
a lot of the designs and sculptural work
when I'm creating the masks I guess to
me it's the ultimate like dr.
Frankenstein moment to actually see a
drawing and go from a drawing to the
sculpture a sculpture to a mask and then
having an actor put it on and when those
eyes open up it's literally an it's
alive type moment it's really gratifying
to see my creations alive and invoking
fear and emotions out of people that see
them now this is like living the dream
you know like I used to draw monsters as
a kid so I often tell people I wish I
could go back in time and like you know
whispered a 8th grade Andrew that's
getting yelled at by the teacher for
drawing monsters like just keep doing it
too because I'm gonna pay out you know
the dream come true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]